frankly we were tad concerned with your
performance history against the deal of
this size but after meeting you to
face-to-face we feel like we're in good
hands on this one we won't let you down
sirs not to mention your it was far too
attractive for us to pass up what did
you mean by that exactly
he means you boys lowball the entire
industry yeah by how much you guys came
in fifty three million dollars lower
than the nearest competition oh okay now
to a question that still has no clear
answer how did two twenty-something
young men land a 300 million dollar
Pentagon contract I have a big idea they
call guys like us war dogs bottom
feeders you make money off of war
without ever stepping foot on the
battlefield
it was meant to be derogatory but we
kind of liked it sorry
she's an emergency sorry don't worry I
have to go first I'm American
you seriously want to drive to Baghdad
David were gun runners let's go run some
guns
give me some attack
come on man go
you drove these through the triangle of
death we drive through all triangles
Cruden your mom's they rush to the new
home then snap they run into this stuff
called me bud they cram down the straw
pulled